لربما بدات اقتحام انصار الرئيس البرازيلي
السابق جياير بونونارو للكونغرس والقصر
الرئاسي في العاصمه برازيليه بدا مفاجئا
للبعض لكن التدقيق في مسار الاحداث خلال
الاشهر الماضيه سينتهي بتوقع الذي حصل
بدات القصه قبل الانتخابات التي اجريت في
اكتوبر الماضي وهي الاكثر استقطابا في
تاريخ البرازيل منذ عقود وتنافس فيها
اليسري لولا دا سيلفا واليمنيين بون
سونارو الذي يوصف بانه يمني شعبووي بعد
جوله الاولى غير حاسمه من الانتخابات
الرئاسيه جلدت جوله اعاده بين الاثنين في
نهايه اكتوبر الماضي تغلب فيها لولا ده
سيلفا بفارق ضئيل بلغ 50 وتسعه اعشار في
المئه لم يعترف بون سونارو بالخساره
واطلقت فيها مات بتزوير النتائج وذهب بعض
مؤيديه لاغلاق الطرق واقامه اعتمامات امام
سكنات الجيش مطالبين بتدخل الجيش لمنع من
تولي رئاسه البرازيل فثالث عشر من ديسمبر
الماضي اقرت المحكمه العليا البرازيليه
فوزا لولا دا سيلفا في الانتخابات وفي
الوقت ذاته هاجم انصار بونسونارو مقر
الشرطه الاتحاديه في العاصمه البرازيليه
واشتبكوا مع قوات الامن في الحادي
والثلاثين من ديسمبر الماضي غادر
بونسونارو البرازيل متوجها الى ولايه
فلوريدا الامريكيه كي يتجنب حضور مراسم
تنصيب سيلفا في الاول من يناير الجاري ادى
لولا ده سيلفا اليمين رئيسا للبرازيل وسط
اجراءات الامنيه مشدده في اعقاب تهديد
انصار بون سونار بارتكابي اعمى عنف